morning Millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy Monday hey I'm just
I'm a broken woman you know we had a big
weekend with a big weekend and but we
were rushed out of New Jersey yesterday
like truly like political refugees yes
and I never got time to process the
hangover because we were so busy fleeing
yeah so I'm now taking on like a
sympathy hangover from yesterday
understood the hangover never hit for me
because as far as fleeing a country goes
yes so he was pretty smooth yeah I mean
here's the thing when you guys come to
my shows it's like so great like family
together but it's torture because like I
left for the venue soundcheck of Mean
Green I like five o'clock and you guys
started drinking at five o'clock so at
the time the show was over at like 10
o'clock
you guys are like let ready to go and
like I haven't even started drinking yet
so every time that you guys come to a
show I have to cram like six hours worth
of drinking into two hours and I always
end up just like blacking out and
falling yeah overdoing it I fell asleep
at the pizza place at Foxwoods yes and
my arms just like went out you know and
then I just just I don't even know what
happened in Jersey yesterday um it was
it was a quick drunk for you yeah don't
worry once we all got tired we got pizza
thanks to the snatchers oh my god by the
way are you always such pizza drama
everyone was yelling at me that I didn't
get enough I fight very brave of you to
just think that like eight people eight
slices it's just like not how the world
we also had like a Carmel cake - yeah
had food at home that car Bell cake he
truly had a pizza party we had like a
kid's birthday party just even the Hat I
was sitting at that dining room table
like with a big piece of cake which a it
first and then the pizza and I thought
to myself like I don't know if I've ever
been this happy no it was truly
delicious it was truly delicious and
then we we ran out of town yeah and you
guys got second so much traffic going to
New Jersey there on the way back Zach
your husband convinced us to take the
ferry and I'm not gonna lie I was very
trepidatious I'm like you know I've seen
the Titanic and it's gonna be a no for
me and I've never been more excited to
say like I was so wrong you were so
wrong we were all wrong we were all
skeptical but it was a beautiful
experience on the high seas I I have to
say that going on the ferry like it was
the most fun I've ever had like the
ferry first of all what they don't tell
you about the ferry stun
like amenities up the wazoo there's a
bar there's toilets two toilets with
real flushes and soap like so clean I
like I mean I looked I did
that's how nice it was I'm sorry to say
and then we had like these delicious
seats with like a table and then like
the view when we did to get over the
barriers you guys need to get off the
ferry like I was going to cry like I had
was having the best time like we were
all just like hanging out talking like
the ferry was everything now I have to
get a house at the Jersey Shore
it was weird cuz when I got home I was
like how did I get here my experience
wasn't treacherous enough no I was I was
lying in bed I'm like I'm already here
yeah no it was just I wasn't so I wasn't
used to like the ease the stress-free
experience and now I'm just like so and
Zac Jackie's husband was like please
don't tell everyone about the fairy on
the toast like then there'll be more
people on it like I love that he thinks
are so influential but like we are and I
just I can't stress enough like how much
of a fan I am of the fairy and the sea
streak the the holding company um the
privately-owned that's why it's so
that's partly owned and I'm gonna invest
yeah I think that's where we should put
our funds I mean we'll talk about it I'd
popular and then yeah it's like and then
it's like mutual interests wherever they
meet well your show was amazing
thank you so nice to meet in the New
Jersey toast of ours toasters Asbury
Park was amazing I felt like I was in
Nashville by the sea no totally and then
we went across the street right I've
never been to Nashville Margo just your
trip next week Labor Day weekend are you
excited by Councillor it was just a
jolly good show and did you know I was
doing the math yesterday you know I had
a lot of free time I will have done 81
shows i watch your Instagram story so I
did over that is crazy that is crazy so
much like I'm so if it works
oh are you are calling me I am coming if
14 more tickets available at girls on
job Commons
yeah I'd highly suggest it I hadn't seen
the show since March and it's just
better matter every time I have a story
that I want to share with and if you've
ever already seen it you can see it
again yeah cuz I've seen it like six
times man I was like I have a personal
journey I want to share that like I'm
borderline embarrassed to say but it's
too funny not to okay because when I got
home yesterday I was just so hungry and
at like four or five o'clock I ordered a
glazed teriyaki which is so good it's
like Chipotle but like Asian so it's
like rice bowls with teriyaki chicken
it's Oh sounds like
you invented it yeah it sounds like I
invented it and it ordered it on an app
and I was still hungry it was taking so
long
and finally Ben went to a concert last
night so I'm all alone just me and Theo
and my phone rings from the doorman and
he's like you got a food delivery but
I'm like what's wrong with food and he's
like I would call the restaurant like
this does not look like ah I just he was
like he's so like frazzled and I just
couldn't understand he was like you'll
see but like don't the guy was like he
just wasn't finishing his sentences and
the food was brought up and I'm like oh
my it looks a little beat up like the
cap was slightly off some of the chicken
import out but like I was so [ __ ]
hungry like you bet your ass ate the
whole thing
then a few hours later I went downstairs
to walk Theo and the doorman was like
Gigi call the restaurant I lied I was
like yeah I got a pretty fun like don't
worry I was like embarrassed and he goes
I've never seen anything like this in my
life like this guy showed up without a
shirt on I delivered the food and he was
like he didn't have shoes on either like
it was so weird and I was like that is
information he should have shared on the
phone obviously if I had known a naked
man and delivered the food I wouldn't
have eaten it but he just said like it
looks like it was bang job there was a
storm outside like okay I'm not judging
the fact that the box was a little
banged up but hadn't you told me that
the man was shirtless I feel as though
that's changes things that definitely
changes things I was mortified on my kid
no I didn't either like I called the
restaurant don't worry Peter that's so
crazy that's like one time I had a glam
squad come to my apartment and she rang
my doorbell and she wasn't wearing shoes
and I looked down the hallway I like was
trying to figure out where her shoes
could be and then she did my hair and
she was great and then she laughed and I
called the doorman I was like was she
wearing shoes when she came building
like and he had he didn't know I was
like well he must have noticed it she's
a better person because I know I think
they have to take your shoes up like
there was asked to me to take my shoes
alone okay
Oh thrown in the purse I didn't think of
anyone I have a different one this is
the weirdest one when I was in high
school I had an SAT tutor at the house
and she fainted I was oh and she said
she was gluten-free and she had to eat
in the soup while we were like studying
and I guess like it had corner there's
something and she fainted right but I
mean like I was
like I didn't know what to do I was like
I'm so like frazzled like I just I froze
and like she woke up and then just left
Wow in Tucson crazy times man crazy
times
crazy times I guess that's what happens
when you Clinton I guess that's what
happens when you try and take the SATs
yeah look what it did make Bautista
Chopin
okay well do you think it's time I don't
know I truly don't know I don't know is
there anything else we haven't Jim oh
well I spent my whole day yesterday
watching the society because the two of
you were watching it on tour and I have
like such FOMO for not being able to
talk about it okay just ten episodes in
like ten hours I have to give credit to
Margaret like we were in this hotel room
where it's like normally I'm like a snot
about hotel rooms like this room but I
had had such a treacherous travel day
like this hotel like I think it was the
Four Seasons it was the best hotel I'd
ever been at and then the TV had Netflix
so we were dying and you know it's so
hard like Netflix like you can't watch
anything like there's nothing nothing to
watch she looks like I was happy about
it like but I also wasn't and then
Martin was like I've heard such good
things about the society and I'm
honestly so trepidatious to always like
starting shows because there's such poor
content out there and I went into it
with the mindset of having absolutely no
idea what it was about and I'm so happy
that I did because like when the kids
got off the bus I was like where the
parents like I didn't know you know yeah
the best show ever such a it's like a
modern Lord of the Flies those kids are
[ __ ] amazing actors and they're not
like being thirst monsters you don't I
mean like feel like all the kids who get
famous for my different shows they like
go to the BB mas you know what I mean
like they're so yeah and like in every
episode their lips get bigger ya know
but like these kids are [ __ ] amazing
actors they're so all of them can cry
yeah excite okay there's a weird thing
with the crying because it's like
they're all stoic and I understand some
people cry like that where it's just
happier you can definitely cry on her
own
oh I feel like there are some people
that are stoic and tears just stream
down their face but like for every
single kid to have that type of cry
Netflix really wanted like good actors
they don't want any [ __ ] Rachel named
Jennifer accident I'll actually cry I
think it's just here drops like I think
they just put [ __ ] in their eyes and
then they're like what it felt like
because the girl who plays Elle is that
her name the pie girl she doesn't cry
when she was sitting in the church
confessing to the priest oh yeah
whatever happened I love love the
priestess she wasn't crying she was like
like I could do that you know there was
no tears she was just like maybe name
her baby they ran out of tear budget no
or maybe she's just one of the ones who
can't cry or I mean she's such a good
actress too when she was having the
seizure or maybe she's supposed to be
like a little bit of a sociopath right
that well that's true it's like which
would be why she doesn't cry let's recap
the show at the end for those who have
never seen it and maybe want to watch it
and we don't want to spoil it and they
should have the same experience that we
it's just such a good show you guys just
watch it it really is very of them so
without further ado it is time for the
Fast Five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast so it's time I
agree with you that the time is now it
is time but I would be like so upset and
like so heartbroken devastated like I
don't know if I could ever recover if I
didn't let you know that today's episode
is brought to you by daily harvest now
that now that warm brother is here the
last thing I want to do is spend my days
trapped indoors standing over a hot
stove that is my worst [ __ ] nightmare
standing over a hot stove
can you imagine there's so much fun
stuff to do during summer I need the
option to just eat and go and that's
what we love about daily you know that's
how we sum up ourselves
it's just it's a great for the summer
thing too but it's also just like when
you're a working woman in the morning so
you see like grab and go with like an
acai bowl a working mom a single mom
sometimes because Ben is a deadbeat dad
with hundred percent daily harvest has
your back for all the deadbeat dads out
there
TLE harvests delivers thoughtfully
source chef's crafted food that is built
on fruits and vegetables you have to
sound laughing I'm trying to do an ad
Mon so you just got jelly harvest
delivers bubbly source it is thoughtful
resource
you German you need to know about
sailing harvest daily harvest delivers
thoughtfully source chef's crafted food
that is built on fruits and vegetables
and can be prepared in less than five
minutes fill your box with more than 65
different options like ready the blend
smoothies refreshing chilled soups
dispatch oh love it it's actually good
spatula I'm very very harvest bowls I
love a gazpacho everything stays fresh
in your freezer until you're ready to
eat it
each jelly harvest cup takes one step to
prepare with room for customization
add your favorite milk to a smoothie and
blend or heat a harvest bowl and top it
with avocado or a fried egg if it's keto
season for you all of the daily hardest
harvests ingredients are sourced and
selected for maximum nourishment and
peak season flavor
I love the smoothies with daily harvest
I can put like my own milk in it I don't
know whatever milk I'm drinking of the
day been has gotten me now on oat milk
oh my god but I could put that in my
butt so much stuff in my fridge and I
throw it up good go to daily harvest a
common enter per mo Code toast to get
$25 off your first box that's
promotional toast for $25 off your first
box at daily harvest calm daily harvest
calm honestly go forth and harvest
honestly thank you for doing that like I
just couldn't get through it and it's
like we got money to make but it was my
thoughts I'm sorry it's just like that's
what happens when like you're so funny
it's contagious
it truly is okay first story is
absorbing some happy news you gotta get
your daily harvest soon some happy news
wedded bliss for Dwayne Johnson to truly
and unknown and I have a lot of thoughts
about this ok Twiggy Johnson is arguably
the most famous person in the world
actually it's not even arguably like I
would say one of the top 20 most famous
people in the world like his this global
presence and he has like the most
personal private life and people just
respect it it's like not fair
yeah well I mean he's cultivated that
for himself and I feel as though he
posts it with his wife on Instagram and
people just like one happiness for him
enjoy so they're not gonna try and like
rip that apart that's also what he's
like projecting in addition to like
being a mega superstars like leave me
alone I also think we don't see him get
paparazzi because he doesn't I can call
them right right yes respect yeah you
know you know what's interesting I feel
like not enough people talk about how
like and I'm not one to pit people
against each other but like I actually
am and I think that there's definitely
like an underlying competition between
the rocky and Jason Momoa like most
it's Hawaiian Oh it's tough and I think
because like the rock got that part in
Moana I totally catapulted it catapulted
him but I don't know Jason Moe is like
out here doing the most I know for the
oceans you know when he's Aquaman true
why can't we share it
I'm just saying like if there was a
pageant for me there is a peace
protection partial Spring Fling Queen
I'm just saying like it's somebody think
about it is something to think about but
I don't know I feel like there's enough
to go around for everyone and they
didn't know that he wasn't already
married he has two daughters right I'm
saying like he's the most famous person
in the world like I should know
everything about him like inside of his
butthole but I don't you see because he
has two daughters one who was Miss
Golden Globe right yes and Miss Golden
Globe thing is like so weird
it's weird I can't believe it still goes
on but it's kind of cool but it's so
like nepotistic Oh 1,000% but it's like
between like the you know the
sexualization of children thing and the
nepotism I didn't think it would exist
in 29 notably but if yes here we are
but it's always like it's like they only
choose the daughters of people like who
are super famous and we don't know the
daughters you know what I mean that
Kelsey Grammer so famous Greer grammer
she was in that show like a minute and
she was great yeah she was a great show
but it's and then of the rock the most
famous person the world his daughter who
and then she was it you know it's like
what are they given to Cassie tape you
know what I mean
yeah she's a little she's famous for the
role that's what I'm saying it's like
you have to be a loser to do it which
obviously is why I haven't been asked
they got married in Hawaii August 18
2019 so so sweet she's a beautiful woman
they look very happy
that's a nice Rock deserves the best
like he brings so many people joy like
all the time like he deserves some joy
and they feel like the people who are
like their whole job is like bringing
people joy like you know the ones who
are the most depressed sort of Sheriff
but I don't see that for him no me
neither
but that's what they say about everyone
yeah like comedians yeah Robin Williams
anything yeah very sad no I got a
question on about some Q&A like do you
feel depressed cuz you're a comedian and
I was like embarrassed to say no I feel
like this would be a great conversation
for you on comedians in cars getting
coffee
you know this is a mound comedians will
not even seem it just like the way it is
and they feel like Jerry Seinfeld could
totally relate for sure but I also feel
is that you just vote I've heard you
speak about it before I don't know about
in public but like just in
life about how you could see how that
happens I think these days how like you
sometimes yeah it helps have a drink
before you go on siege but then like
you're drinking at every show I said
that to Margo and I never drink at shows
but if you guys are there like
afterwards I do but when I first started
I was like so nervous that I use like to
take a shot before every show and then
some random like manager at a comedy
club in like st. Louis was telling me
how like on how so many comedians become
alcoholics because they rely on that one
drink before every show and then it's
one and then it's two and then it's like
you can't do a show without it and
you're working so much that you need
drink and I don't even know if this guy
realized I can saved my life because I
was like I'm never drinking again
like I used to have a bottle of tequila
my writer I'm like no thanks like
Pharrell yeah so 81 bottles of tequila
yes 99 bottles of tequila yes for sugar
81 shows but then it got me thinking
comedians depression oh yeah so the
alcohol definitely is more of a
depressive but then I also was thinking
like sometimes I'm not depressed but
sometimes I feel like I am on the road
and then we do the show if we do meet
and greets like I give my all you know
and then it's like when it's time to go
home like I give nothing because I have
nothing left to give and like me and
been like never go out to dinner anymore
because all I want to do is lie at home
you know I don't know if that's
depression I don't think it is I think
I'm just like trying to be dramatic okay
that's you trying to find balance
you said it work-life balance it's all
the rage totally you know what's great
work-life balance our sister Olivia she
does she's like always working and
always living and she's always like why
think yes you know she's one's dinner
every night every night that's what she
was saying she made dinner for us um in
the Jersey at the park of Asbury this
weekend the tacos supreme supreme
sometimes I just go to lovey's house for
a good meal yeah actually I don't know
how she does it she's like that movie
was heretical Parker how does she do it
that you know Sarah Jessica burger
should be embarrassed of like her
catalogue of movies first she ruined the
world with Carrie Bradshaw I've taken a
lava and then like she really was a part
of some of the worst movies of all time
remember those bangs in failure launch
Oh bad Laura the Family Stone Oh woof
I'm gonna say like nobody ever only
regards her as like this like
world-famous actress and I just want to
put it out there like she's awful like
sorry I said it
yeah you know it's not the first time
we've said it no I mean I like and okay
remember how was
she addressed how like there was a New
York Times article or like the cut
article that said the Carrie Bradshaw it
was actually the worst oh sure and she
responded to me like oh look in such a
caring way Oh Carrie was so endearing
it's just telling the self-aware enough
to know like that she was just like the
worst protagonist and like yes the show
was super important like talking about
sets like different types of women and
and for sure but like no one talks it up
about how Carrie Bradshaw was the devil
yeah but nothing when we started this
show that is why we started as soon as
it gets justice for David Foster but
like we've actually already gotten it
just serve up justice for like the other
wit for Miranda truly that is your cross
to bear my cross to bear in this
lifetime is getting justice her Miranda
because growing up everyone was like oh
I don't want to be bad that she has
short hair and I just like follow the
law because I just was a follower I was
Oliver yeah and I can just wanted to be
cool but like the more I've actually
watched his show as an adult it's like
okay hear me out Miranda was the only
one with an actual job like Samantha
like was a publicist Charlotte didn't
work and carry like wrote five words a
day and then was wondering why she
couldn't pay around yeah and then send
her money and she I'm kidding I lived in
a townhouse yeah any nobody feds
then Miranda was like the only one who
actually like figured her life out you
know and it's like she didn't even think
tells more it's like how hard it was
firm rent it's like be a single mom at
one point and just have like this weird
relationship with Steve and then also
like have a burgeoning career like she's
a modern woman
yeah she's honestly she was before her
time how does she do it I don't know she
should have gotten her apartment with
her Ralph Lauren paint like she was
truly an icon I agree and I feel like I
get made fun of for like wanting to be
Miranda but like when I look up to these
lady he's like no offense none of them
are even remotely like I don't want to
be anything like that except maybe a
little bit like Miranda and okay Lori
Samantha well I'll be as skinny as its
Kari I'll take it but you know actually
it wasn't great like for someone who was
like so obsessed with fashion like
weight like the way she talked about
fashion like she couldn't about a closet
I guess
it wasn't for everyone but she took
chances yes she took chances whatever I
have but I think that's around with a
lot of shows is that the
like sucks so hard very hot chairs for
housewives Serena van der Woodsen
actually not cat for Newton no no not
yet yes that's a that's a recurring
theme that actually a cinema cinephiles
cinephiles have discovered here on the
chest it's like you fall in love with
the show and you realize like wait I
hate the main character they make the
worst decisions yeah and that's like I
don't know I think that has to be the
case in order for the show to work
because the protagonist has to like be
going through stuff right and inevitably
being the shitty person yeah just being
a [ __ ]
yes inevitably some anything about okay
next story some good news for Ashley
Graham who is pregnant and is praised
over her naked selfie with stretch marks
okay now to make this about me but we
saw Ashley Graham how many months ago at
the Jonas Brothers concert yeah like at
the beginning of June she was totally
pregnant right she like has a full bump
she's been hiding this for ad to have
been and she wasn't drinking she was
eating from okay there was a really
alcohol there yeah it's true it was
honestly it was a sadler to drive and
yes the 31 year old model and husband
Justin Urban announced on Instagram yeah
that she's pregnant with their first
child and on son she's another one she's
like such a big star but then she's like
low-key married and has a nice life it's
honestly like it's the way to be famous
you know that's what I'm working on I I
don't think I'm doing a good job but I'm
working on it
good luck on Sunday she shared a naked
selfie the photo was taken below her
neck and shows part of her breast arm
side stomach butt and thigh it also
shows some of her stretch marks she
wrote same same but a little different
the photo was met with mostly praise
yeah because it's not every day you see
a photo like this on Instagram and I
mean ugly I don't know what time period
Ashley Grimes living in but it's
definitely brave season wherever she is
you know because that was super brave
yeah it was brief it may just helps move
the needle you know that's the thing
actually grandmas done so much for the
world you know what she continues to do
and she continues - I [ __ ] love her
eyeliner Dyke the way she's gorgeous
like when I saw her I was like oh shucks
she truly has a presence to her yeah she
like glows
well we got she's slowing cuz she's
pregnant Margo Darren and there it is
you said it not me
yes she totally was pregnant when sorry
does it say how many months alone she
has it doesn't but typically when do you
announce I mean
you access to announcement for three
months but I don't think you would
really show a big bump three months she
looks like five months you think even
she commute if she's three or five she
wouldn't would have been pregnant right
well no three it's already August but
it's two months ago right and June
should get the album come out June 4th I
don't know why I know that I'm getting
so late for the jota's about this
concert like just the content they're
putting out on their social channels now
like like they're doing such a good job
of like promoting themselves like that
moment would they all put on like mana
color monochromatic thank you suits here
for it
all of it doing ticket and if I go to a
show and there's not a J sister they're
like I'm demanding a refund today will
be to New York we're going yeah yeah nej
sister nej sister and you know they keep
doing things on their Instagram story
it's like what song should we play on
tour and like you can respond and I have
literally responded and left to comment
on every single one of their social
channels begging them to play play my
music from Camp Rock and I as far as I
know it's not a part of the set have you
guys seen the setlist I saw it I tried
not to look at it cuz it's actually what
I don't want to spoil because I know all
of their songs so I don't need to study
and from what I opened up rollercoaster
so oh my god but I know the best part of
the tour is my queen and I recently
become a stand of bebe Rexha is opening
for them wow she's such a great
performer yeah it's gonna be Rach how
you guys are gonna go yeah yeah Thursday
Labor Day weekend I'm leaving Friday
okay I don't lose my mind when they play
roller coaster like it was fun when we
were young but now we're older I know
and it's still fun and they're abroad I
go back and ride that roller coaster
some but I think about it's gonna be
great what throwback to do they play any
camp rock I got yeah I do they play
[Music]
yeah it's like rock band but with our
mouth do you have a clear och them
growing up like with your friends I
think you didn't maybe like once but you
know I don't like it yeah
okay did you play rock band yes I feel
like there's so many like old-school
songs that I know only because of rock
band you know what scream Bop know that
is because of what's the one with this
our hero same thing um hit me with your
best shot so I know that's not know that
song before no also like to join your
friends to fight over who got the drum
because I was like obviously the best
one everything she chants as part as an
instrument I think I think they should
really bring back rock band that was
really a great game and so good for like
children like learning musical this
spring music ow
that's some time directed by mr. bus
agree well speaking of children good
boys has ended Hollywood's comedy
drought the r-rated movie about
foul-mouthed 12 year olds was number one
with about 21 million dollars the year's
largest opening total for an original
comedy this is so exciting mostly
because Jacob Tremblay is at the helm
and I hope to have trembles just like
making money you know I think that he is
Universal Pictures and a gaggle of
foul-mouthed 12 year olds proved over
the weekend that even the Netflix epic
comedies that's definitely not right
comedies can still pack a punch at the
box office if you're wondering why I'm
raining on my phone it's because I ran
out of New York Times articles on my
iPad okay like no I'm not one to you
notice journalism but like the fact that
you have to pay for like certain
articles and not others so it's like if
you read too many you only get a few
free ones a month so I ran out on my
iPad because of everything with Jeffery
I've seen and so now I have to read it
on me so what you're saying is that the
end of the day it's always Jeffrey
Epstein's fault that's exactly when in
doubt did you see Jeffrey obscene for
his birthday I got three twelve-year-old
french girls yeah I saw it in the Sun
this morning
French campers terrible terrible bio mom
oh good voice about the r-rated
misadventures of three preteen buddies
collected an estimate when starting
dollars someone in the comments Chanel
Weatherly said they played play my music
at their
show in Tampa okay there's no that's
crazy so it's not impossible I feel as
though I might be responsible I feel as
though they also need to play send it on
did you see that it was a 10-year
anniversary of send it on
no I didn't is a song for chains I
remember that was like comic thing cover
all the Disney stars are now I feel like
they've all just like really bounce back
like Miley's where she's meant to be not
with Liam but whatever Jonas Brothers
they're Selena I don't know jury's still
out sure Ystad Demi I don't know but
like I think she's gonna be the next
Bachelorette I think she's in a good
place
me too oh she definitely is she's new
manager Scooter Braun so I think when
like things are quieting you're not on
tour like you're probably doing well yes
us touring artists it's just it takes a
toll it does take a toll Oh
segue back to this movie plane in Philly
to last night oh my god is it a part of
the set oh I just didn't look it's
possible I'll die look it's the best
song I just remember listening to that
on my iPod Nano like feeling like I
could conquer the world because I could
and you can and I did didn't play this
is me and then mash it up with greatest
showmen because that's what they should
be - I mean I don't know that there's
that in tune but hopefully this movie's
good boys looks so good for so many good
summer flicks and it's like I'm finally
easy so I feel like when I whenever I
need a movie like during downtime
there's no good movies and now there's
so much that I want to see well that's
not my problem my problem with going to
the movies is like now that it's become
like an old school thing to do like
movie theaters are downsizing and now
there's only like 30 seats in a theater
and in the summer it's so [ __ ] hot
it's the only place with air
conditioning so you literally can't see
a movie in the summer in the city it's
like trying to get tickets to the Super
Bowl sort of yeah I imagine or you have
to like plan in advance which is like I
don't I can't tell you that in five days
I'm gonna see movie you know but I do
want to see good boys because I'd love
to support our local Jacob Tremblay and
it looks like a bomb film and I'm
hearing for comedies making a comeback I
didn't know comedies were like going
through a rough time
yeah comedies romantic comedies it's
tough times not for Netflix Margot says
to finish the new romantic I did what
you think I thought it was good I mean
honestly it's well they only had 20
minutes left and like nothing new
happened really um but it was it was
good the new romantic is a Netflix
original that highlights the ups and
downs of being a sugar baby and I just
have to say it's highly unrealistic
because this girl gets like teamed up
with like a hot rich like normal guy who
likes she actually ends up liking and
that never
happens you get like freaks who like
pick their belly buttons will finish the
movie and then and then hit me up okay
Oh does he turn out to be that guy don't
tell me all I'm saying is like the guys
that you mean I'm seeking Arrangements
like never look like the dude from the
movie like this is hot I'm seeking
arrangement it was like a mutual setup
doesn't matter that guys who need to pay
people to hang out with them don't look
like that but you'll find out why he's
paying like no Joe Burnham you don't
even find out really sorta it's that
whatever whatever okay we'll talk about
it when you finish it cool everyone
should check it out
your man days and also I watch a couple
of sugar baby movies on the Lifetime
movie club recently and I'm really
curious like is it as big as it seems
like on every college campus just a
breeding ground for sugar babies getting
their tuition paid yeah well oh honey oh
do you I don't know any sugar babies
like myself but like I'd be like NYU was
a prime breeding ground because it's the
highest tuition yeah and it's the city
that there was big city slickers right
right and it's like the cost of living
in New York is like you meet a sugar
daddy
yeah yeah I have a sugar daddy see yeah
yeah he's making that money did you see
that ad he posted yeah as a partner for
Amazon this weekend he was kind of big
deal yeah he's not too got his own
dressing room he's not too old for
Amazon okay he got his own dressing room
mm-hmm very special
okay next story father of Elizabeth
Smart comes out as gay setting he's
leaving the Mormon Church okay it's been
a while since because there was Mormon
yes they were in Utah they were Mormon
AF Wow yeah that makes it more than is
like it's like what happened to her well
it's it it all is kind of tied together
because I think they were super involved
in the church and so they had they used
to you know give back and give
opportunities to like people in the
community and the guy who owned up
kidnapping her was also someone who's
working at their house some of the
church family I don't know if it's
through the church but you know they're
the philanthropic nature oh I know this
I would sit down agree we're going
between like 1991 1994 you know
Elizabeth smart backwards and forwards
which is why this is a real shock this
story plagues our house like Jackie
could not sleep she would walk around
the house at night locking every door
like a freak but you were six we had so
many doors yeah we did
and now I have one door you have to
change this know this story like really
and I I'll never stop talking about
Elizabeth smart because I'll never get
over like how odd it is that she's
famous for having been kidnapped like do
you think she's a nine-to-five job
perhaps but I do think she's quite
philanthropic now as well right but like
she has to pay her rent you think like
her book sales just I just want to know
like what are the financial like
logistics of being a former kidnappee
who got famous I think the book sales
are definitely helping that she I don't
think she like started to live above her
means once she got came famous so she
definitely is like a nice nest egg right
um and that allows her to do all the
giving Mac works which is like so crazy
because if that happened to me I'd be
like [ __ ] you all yeah Jackie do you
think that she does Instagram ads I
would love to check her definitely makes
money Elizabeth Smart official oh wow
she's so pretty she verified yes
won't you be it's the least they could
do no totally curious oh my god wait I
just stumbled upon the most pertinent
caption of Elizabeth Smart do you think
she's a toaster she doesn't know that
would be like a service like she's
infected as so much like it's possible
that we've affected already this is her
most recent caption on a photo for those
who followed me and don't know why how
or who I am my name is Elizabeth Smart
most people remember me from when I was
14 years old and was kidnapped for my
bed at knifepoint in the middle of the
night I was held captive when she was 14
that's like old like you remember
everything yeah I was held captive for
the next nine months where I was oh my
god
raped tortured and abused one of the
greatest miracles happened in my life
when I was rescued by the police because
everyday people saw something not quite
right and reported it over the last 16
years I've moved on to be come an
advocate for survivors specifically of
kidnapping and sexual violence in
whatever form that I maybe I haven't
continued to work and can challenge and
change the mentality that many victims
face
why didn't you go why did you on the
bond date why do you scream why don't
you fight back etc I try to focus on
prevention education but to those
victims out there I want them to know
that they are not alone and have nothing
to be ashamed of it doesn't matter if
they are raped by an intimate partner or
a stranger it's never okay and rape is
rape there's never a situation that
makes rape acceptable or less important
I will continue to do my best
create change my personal life centers
around my husband and my three children
Chloe James and Olivia I love horses
dogs running in a really good cake me
too Elizabeth Smart Wow honestly icon I
stand I stand
Elizabeth Stan like good for what she
and her family can cue I think so her
dad left the Mormon Church but this
dress is just gonna be more of a Mormon
vibe I don't think that she has I think
she's super involved and bring um Young
University he's at a Mormon school it's
a Mormon College yeah why do you know
that um I just I'm always thinking about
bringing young because never remember
his name it's always at the tip of my
tongue so I'm glad that I remembered
today but because I saw Book of Mormon
so there was like Joseph Smith but then
like when he died it was bringing me on
me and marker were just on the road
somewhere and we saw we drove past the
birthplace of Joseph hey Smith Eddie
yeah I said Margo Joseph Smith and
you're like who's fat have you seen one
yes Ben it was not me
maybe when you were driving to her mind
does that mean ah yes New York I can't
remember anything yeah I don't need to
be put in hospice like I literally need
an aide
it's so embarrassing you have us you're
Eve that's that's what the show is
trying to like rejigger my memory yeah
we're doing a good job thank you Mario
yes it was been well Edie smart the
father kidnapping survivor Elizabeth
Smart has revealed he's gay he came out
in an emotional letter to friends and
family via facebook messenger announcing
that he would be leaving his wife Louis
and the Mormon Church quote I have
recently acknowledged myself in my
family that I am gay the decision to be
honest and truthful about my orientation
comes with its own set of challenges but
at the same time it is a huge relief I'm
so happy for him I really am but like
why facebook Messenger weird platform
especially for an older gentleman you
know you know Jax laugh and get
one-to-one or like a mask I don't know
and then to people like comment below I
don't want to take away from the story
because I really am like so happy for
him but like like they have endured so
much like treacherous nests and their
lives like they just deserve peace but
I'm just I'm hung up on the facebook
messenger of it all I agree maybe he
tried to make it his status and then he
got confused like dad's on the Internet
yeah Facebook Messenger is super
confusing it actually is with those
stupid gifs and like animate and if they
have the worst among Chinese is separate
out to separate app so maybe he thought
he was going to Facebook putting in a
status but he just send it to someone
who sends it to NBC News no totally
that's what happened that is so
upsetting well if he came out like in
his private life how did NBC News get it
I don't know they obtained it they
snatched it they were the snatchler if
somebody like that's a total breach of
privacy not cool yeah unless he was the
same I mean we don't know they said
messenger there's so many questions yeah
right like I'm just I'm left with so
many questions that need answers because
of the facebook messenger yeah well he
seems like a happy man I'm happy kid
today thank you so do you think you're
like I was hoping you were gonna say
that
yeah sometimes I like to ingest the
compliment and like explain why I look
cute and I forget to say oh you know
that's so funny because I've actually
recently learned that like I cannot take
a compliment compliment my shirt wow I
love your shirt I always like downplay
what I have like come on let me answer
oh cool earring oh thanks for like $2
how am i I didn't say anything I always
like lower I don't know what it is it's
like am i insecure like anything but
someone compliment something I might or
like tell me on the skinny you look so
thin I mean I really I like a literary
habits updating you know like I always
downplay like the compliment you're like
knocking yourself down I think it's
actually a humility thing I think so too
you know you're just so humble but you
do look really cute thanks oh yeah
except the complan I've been really
trying to like re diversify the Wardrobe
right and it's super hard it's super
hard I think you go on air every day
like I mean I know I did wear the jacket
like one week ago and this dress also
when we go and these shoes also when we
could go but like separately it's super
hard like I need a constant revolving
door of clothing you really do and
that's why I love Frank and oak yes me
too
I'm always looking to discover those key
pieces of clothing that are versatile
comfortable and stylish and on top of
that I've been trying to find clothes
that don't have a huge impact on the
environment but shopping for myself can
be such a pain Cheerilee like I know I'm
a girl I'm like supposed to like
shopping but I'm not gonna lie like I I
hate it ya know it's pretty [ __ ]
treacherous so you can subscribe to the
style plan by Franco nope it's a
subscription box and for men and women
curated by a combination of amazing
style
it's an AI ooh how retro the process is
system opposite about your how modern
yeah how progressive huh futuristic
the process is very simple you tell them
a little bit about yourself by taking a
style quiz preview your monthly
subscription box and then you could take
seven days to decide what you love and
send back what you don't want a quiz yes
you did the subscription I did the
subscription I took the quiz so you tell
them what you like what you don't like
you even tell them like what kind of
colors you like to see you don't like to
wear what you do like to wear what
patterns you would never wear exactly
then like the next day they send you a
preview of your box where you can like
pick items that you actually want to
receive and ones that like are not for
you and then they learn about you along
the way so I picked my box got my box
and I got like the cutest stuff that is
different from what I would normally
bags I'm able to like take some chances
because like Frank and oak are shopping
right that's true so it's exciting
that's very interesting to discover what
your wardrobe is missing try style plan
by Frank Anoka completely risk-free go
to Frank and oak calm slash toast and
you'll get you'll get $25 off your first
subscription box that's Frank and oak
calm slash toast for $25 off your first
subscription box Frank and superb and
oak calm fr A&K and oayk a calm slash
toast $25 off your first subscription
box I really love it
camera sign on look amazing hey okay
Nathan final story it's definitely some
biz news I'm curious to get your take on
it because it's right businesses let me
get my jacket together yes straight
Weight Watchers Weight Watchers is under
fire for selling diets to children I
heard as young as eight Weight Watchers
introduced kirbo with the K by WW which
is their rebrand for adolescence to age
8 to 17
ww is facing back ww takes longer to say
than Weight Watchers no and this makes
no sense because they rebranded 2ww as
like in an efforts like being more
politically correct and then they're out
here like shelling diets for children WW
is facing backlash over the new apps
some nutritionists worry
kirbo could promote unhealthy
relationships with food for children
okay so I'm really perplexed because
like as someone who you know has been
has been skinny it's like somewhere in
the middle right now I think the diets
are not bad and there's like a war on
diets now like diet it's like you can't
say that word anymore it's like the D
word and I'm not here for that but like
really seeing a diet plan that geared
for kids like if a kid is fat like he'll
be fine you know sort of but obesity is
a big problem in this country one in
five young people are obese and some
yeah but like a big weight they do need
the tools that adults yes but a
corporate company like making a diet
plan like geared towards kids just seems
weird like when kids are eight or ten
and they're chubby like they're gonna be
fine
maybe but maybe not and sometimes you
really do need the tools and you need to
like learn what a calorie is and it's
it's educational like I have so many
friends they need to learn like the
parents to teach them yes but the
parents are teaching the parents are
letting them eat
also if the parent is not the parents a
curse on them up for this anyway you
know that's true okay they're gonna make
finding in the App Store right no it's
so silly like and as a brand that's like
forward-facing and like is obviously
very in tune with like what the current
like climate is because they change
their names to WWE just so they didn't
like you know the word weight is like
triggering or something like they're
obviously very aware of like of how
they're being perceived and this just
seems like they definitely could have
avoided this majorly so what they should
do nothing for the children what about
the children I'm sorry like at some
point it's like I didn't see that TV
show but the one on Netflix who's like
parents keep loving their kids get
abducted yes objective it's like where
are the parents like at some point it's
like why is it Oprah's problem to make
sure kids aren't getting that like where
are their parents okay but the parents
aren't doing something so it's not
Oprah's problem she's enough on her
plate I don't know I don't think it's
the worst idea I definitely I understand
the fear that getting like kids you know
so like once you start calorie counting
like that's the rest of your life enjoy
it's that the obesity rate goes down is
the point of the program to educate the
children or to educate the parents
children I don't like it it's weird but
you also have to like start learning
these habits at a young age because when
you're older like you're set in your
ways and maybe the children have a
chance well you know I feel like maybe
we have an interesting take on this
because we did go to fat camp we're at a
very young age when 11:11 did you say
that I wish that the obesity rate in the
country would go down okay I wish that
too but like just just something like a
little closer to you know I would love
like a Netflix special
or like to be on an episode of comedians
in cars and obviously health wealth and
happiness for my entire family and
exciting family and everyone in this
room um and so it is so what we have a
definitely an interesting perspective
because we went to fat camp and you know
I've always said like fat camp was great
such great memory it's like first
boyfriend but I don't think it was so
great you know like for my mental state
like just being inundated with like food
and dieting it like such a young age and
I and I maybe I'm just being you know
lazy but I attribute a lot of my weight
gain to that so I think maybe we we take
an interesting you know perspective on
it I feel as though we're kind of the
experts on the matter because we both
had the same upbringing but where it's
like a nature versus nurture thing where
I was the complete opposite where it was
like I was always gonna be like on top
of what like cuz I grew up with a slow
metabolism I'll you had to fast when
it's like I didn't I need a lot of thumb
I needed to learn like how to diet and I
did at camp but like an app wouldn't do
the same thing right but don't you think
like if a kid is nine years old and he's
or she is like being like force like
count calories or just like think of
food as like a weird like I wouldn't you
should just think of food as like
something you eat to like live you know
like fuel 100 percent in a perfect when
it's like unhealthy to like just have
those like have a toxic relationship
with food I agree
but they're like for an obese child
their relationship with food is already
toxic in another way that's true but I'm
not talking about obese I'm sure about
chubby like kids jelly
okay but I'm we're talking about in the
obesity also like what qualifies as
obese cuz I'm pretty sure like one time
I went to the doctor and I was probably
10 pounds more than I am now and they
told me I was obese well that's crazy
because you're like I should it's just
like I can't I'm like 10 pounds heavier
do you read me city join when we were in
Nashville and we were going somewhere
and you could walk through music what
you guys say to remember and naturally
actually me and Jackie like have this
picture of the two of us like at our
absolute fattest that like this picture
like haunts me like if this picture ever
made it to the internet I would die but
that's not what I was saying we were
going somewhere we could walk through
the Music City Museum and we were
walking through the Convention Center
and it was obesity week which is like we
couldn't tell if it was like although
these people getting together like
skinny people talking about celebrating
on paper we combat such an odd name for
the event because I'm pretty sure it was
like getting rid of obesity but I just
it really sounded like oh like the it
just sounds like obese people getting
together yeah we still don't know but we
were there I should have been because we
were so [ __ ] fat maybe one day we'll
share that picture problem no never
never when you lose it you're
embarrassing for like I think me I think
me I think it might be me
it's the wart like if we shouldn't blow
that picture up and put it on our
fridges you know yeah and our snack
cabinets in our Patrick [ __ ] generate
local drain read that was a big trip for
us if I could just somehow get like one
of the employees at my Duane Reade cuz
every time I walk Co I like oh and if I
could get one of the employees just like
stand at the front door with that huge
picture of me like I think that would
work my local Duane Reade is like slowly
becoming like last night I bought like
Kraft Mac and Cheese at a Hershey bar
like I was just so hungry when I walked
the I'm like I burned the calories like
I could do it yeah sort of is that what
you have for dinner though well no I had
that big chicken oh my god I had such
good pasta for dinner last night
from where from Serafina and then I had
to WWE bars because UW bars I do I got
them in my grocery delivery like they're
cream butter basic sort of melted and
then I poked their ice cream bars I'm
[ __ ] delicious yes yeah they were
really really good weight watchers and
is actually the only diet I've ever had
I'm sorry I did WW and those only diet I
ever really had success with and
eventually it stopped working because
like those [ __ ] dessert bars like
four points eh like the one that's like
a mock Snickers it's so delicious like I
literally ate the whole box and I think
you can have 60 points a day and if a
point is a point then like can't I just
have twelve
ice cream bars yes technically sure yeah
but I don't think that wouldn't
necessarily keep you full no like that's
actually the Watchers is like is
actually really important it's like you
can have twelve ice cream bars or you
could have 65 salads you know it's like
it's actually an important valuable
lesson right which kids could stand to
learn yo new app
kirbo with the candy use code totes
I'm kidding I'm getting totally getting
maybe one day anyways agree disagree
sure I just it's nice when we disagree
cuz it never happens yeah it's nice have
some civil discourse yeah does something
truly underrated about civil discourse
and in this day and age no one is
civilly discourse and I'm here like that
is my mission in this world it's like
it's okay like I'd really feel actually
really strongly about it like nobody
agrees on anything and it's like that's
fine but like why can't you just talk
about other human beings like hit me be
civil it's like from Real Housewives to
politics like just talk it out I totally
agree unless you're an L VP Stan yeah
they get the [ __ ] out Boyd anti-vaxxer
like honestly I'm sorry I had no time
for you and I don't want to hear what
you have to say cause you're dumb okay
very fair okay but other than that like
super civil those are the fast side
stories we have a lot of TV to recap
southern charm real houses of Orange
County
list everything you'll have size of
Orange County because it was actually I
mean the pig emoji video heard around
the world is so ok I have a problem
because I firmly I'm on the side of
history where it's like you cannot talk
about someone else's appearance like you
are trash if you call a woman a pig and
call it fat like as I always say there's
a special place in hell for men who call
women that are also women who call women
that people who call women hatton but
Vicki Gunvalson is saying last season
that Kelly does coke and has now
continues to say it she has removed the
line yeah like you can't now say like
how dare you say something about my
looks like you you made it okay for us
to say crazy things about each other so
you cannot use you she is actually no
right to be mad at Kelly even though I
don't think what Kelly said was right
Vicki made it okay for that like what
Kelly said was insulting what Vicki said
could land her in jail yes and I feel
like that goes back to when Vicki said
that David beats Shannon yep and it's
like the exact same thing and so she
doesn't learn her lesson where it's like
there are things that you can say that
are just mean and then there are things
that you can say that are defamatory
damaging and you can't take it back it's
like it's toothpaste squirted out of the
bottle right the second you know you
actually can I don't agree with that no
because if you squeeze it again and then
you put the nozzle by that toothpaste
that's out and then you open it it does
talk about it you're talking about the
littlest amount say you press it down
I'll go shooting out you can't get that
back in it depends you know how
determined you are okay I totally agree
with what you're saying and it was just
frustrating to watch um
and now it's just crazy I wish the
housewife's was like a little bit more
in real time because right now like
Kelly is going out of a camera and
Shannon like and it seems like they're
on good tongues now so it's just
confusing and it looks like that she
broke up with her man she did but they
like had a bunch of like Instagram posts
to each other like with just saying how
much respect they had for one another
and how she really enjoyed their time
together it was just that I get Caitlin
Carter situation it's like the weirdest
public breakup that like they keep doing
post about each other yeah well even
though sorry sorry the scene where they
did a flashback where they wanted to go
and business together like portable
skincare for TV I'm not an entrepreneur
and I've never been a Chuck tank but I
do have to say I could look into I for
these things and that was the worst idea
for a product like teens who are
children of divorce so that when they go
to their dad's house
there's okay so our only customers are
children but then of those children it
has to be those who have divorced
parents still 50% that's right for me
but then of those divorced parents like
the only kids who really like you know
you skincare are girls so that's already
another 50% then there to give a [ __ ]
enough about their skin to buy the
product like by the time they have to
have a mom who's committed to skincare
right he's not right right so then by
the time they will attempt like their
entire audience here I just Julie oh my
but actually low keep up so that 40
which is caladiums oh my I love her and
but she's so wise I can't believe that
she's only 12 like that continues to
amaze me yeah and you know when they're
going into business together it's
already you shouldn't be going into
business with someone a few months into
our relationship the whole things and so
that's why probably even though they're
broken up they're being respectful
because now like they're in business
yeah you just don't mix business with
pleasure
no Jackie just don't I hear you and I
totally agree and the whole thing was
really here and the first episode I was
like oh man I love him like she should
be getting a plastic surgeon in Orange
County like perfect housewife real a
plastic surgeon relationship everything
then I saw them talking about going to
business together and like this
relationship is doomed and then I keep
shooting in this office and it's just
business with his monogrammed
doctor's jacket yeah and it's got Ussery
written all over it however
Shannon's facelift looks amazing as
Shannon looks so good I've never really
um
stood or a scene I think facelifts are
like super dramatic and you know only to
be done like in the most dire of
circumstances but this was a mini
facelift and it was like outpatient I
think I need a facelift now no I mean I
already got one it was she looks so good
she looks so that he did great work and
for that I'm glad for him that he has
good advertise and I just like I'd like
Shannon so much like her personality
like I enjoy even her mundane seems like
her sending her daughter off to prom
like I was living for it at her
embarrassing her dress her eyes really
short but I know it's like usually like
when oh my god like I hate to hearken
back to Chris Lee but like in so many
episodes of Chris Lee like sadhana came
in in like a dress to the floor and
Chris Todd is like that dresses so short
and it's like not but in this scene in
particular like that dress was like up
that girl's vagina and I can not believe
her mom let her leave the house like
that I know but I think she's just super
tall and her mom didn't wanna make you
feel yeah and the Kurt she was so proud
of her legs and like she had such
confidence at such a young age like you
don't want to dim that comment and like
anything she would have said in that
situation like could have been damaging
for life you know Shannon such a good
mom and like her kids are really just
like good kids and you can always tell
like a lot about a housewife by their
kids cuz like who taught us that um
Margot Joseph she said she hates to yell
stab but her kids are amazing like
they're super smart well-spoken girls
and it says a lot about to know and
that's how I feel about Kelly Todd like
her kid is amazing like yeah super
self-sufficient and like funny and and
say what you want about Kelly job she's
a great [ __ ] mom agreed and I still
like her right now which is on the show
I don't know what goes down between her
and Tamra and Tamra's here last week and
even she didn't know what goes down so
jury's out I'm where I will land on that
soon
uh but I feel like Kelly and I like
Bronwyn that's seen where like she was
in the lingerie I was like really
crunchy and stupid but I feel like
that's like a hazing ritual yes for a
new house right in the bathtub have to
do one cringeworthy scene with your
partner to prove that you have what it
takes and that's why her husband was
slowly on board you know yeah he was
like he's ready he wants his wife to be
like a full-time housewife but her and
everything was really great and it's
like she came into two hammers house and
I feel as though Tamra's not always like
the nicest to the new girls neither
shadow nor does she need to me and they
just like immediately liked her and I
was like what is it about her it's not
like there are tons of like pretty young
sweet things that come through and they
don't like them but there's something
about her that's like super welcoming
and I just think she's gonna be a great
asset and even when Tamara was a
shut up inside last week she was like
thanking Andi for bringing Bronwyn into
her that never happens I think a lot of
it had to do with the fact that she met
Shannon first and Shannon just like they
were drinking so Shannon automatically
liked her and it made it easier for
everyone to like her because Shannon has
always like not really been into the new
people but I think also she met Shannon
at the right time because Shannon's her
best Shannon right now her best Shannon
sells yeah and maybe a year ago she
wouldn't have liked Bronwyn because it
was like you know she didn't like
herself it's a very interesting call
yeah okay so other than that it looks
like it's gonna be a jolly good season
it really does it's off to a great start
and like the biggest stands on Twitter
are just like dying that you there like
petitioning that they're not gonna watch
and like honestly I don't care like I'm
so over Vicki they can go hang out with
the LVP stands and from what I hear
Vicki's integral to the season so she'll
definitely be back next year like
sometimes you just seem you need to work
for it you need a break yeah we in the
words of Ross Geller we were on a break
it's all so crazy that we just did a
whole Orange County recap for about
eight minutes and didn't mention Emily
and Jeana oh my god you know what and
they were like on their own show Emily's
life is so sad like actually watching it
like makes me depressed like this is
pretty sad - actually I think like with
the deal like now it's you want to know
why because Emily like acknowledges her
hardships she's like you know my
relationship with my husband is not
great right now like I'm really
overwhelmed with the kids and my
practice like she acknowledges but like
she was like trying to act like it's all
fine but like it's so not like that's
what makes it sadder
yeah and at least she's not in the
casita like honestly that casita like
made me want to cry yeah
and that with them like saying cuz he
does if it was like the best new idea
never say in its pouch are approved
right you know like them Kate saying
cocido I'm like let's call it what it
was a shack a shed yes so I'm glad she's
out of the casita and that her new house
is fine also the hair the testimonials
that she's been doing she has a new face
yeah she looks better in the
testimonials that she does I disagree I
don't know what she did maybe she
lightened her hair a lot now she's
platinum I like that the light hair is
so terrible but maybe and maybe that's
why she looks so different but it also
looks like she has a new fotch maybe
maybe she went to Kelly's boyfriend
maybe maybe Emily's life is so sad like
that dinner party where like she was
waiting for him with a cake and even
come with the cake because she said all
right Shane whatever like I just like I
actually wanted to solve it in my head
like it was
it's like she's with his parents awful
awful awful
oh my god she does so much I actually
really like her and I want her to get
away from jeana because jeana's like a
toxic disease she needs to get in the
mix but she has so much going on at home
that I don't know that she could be a
trace Amiga right and I forgot that like
she doesn't really get along with
Shannon and Shannon I guess blocked on
Instagram so that's kind of like a
roadblock but I really want Emily like
join the group because Jeana is just
like not cutting it for me and like if
Jeana doesn't come back I'll be fine but
I actually like Emily and I think she
has potential to be a good housewife but
she's getting sidetracked by like her
main husband and her terrible best
friend Gina I don't know I don't mind
Gina and I don't mind Emily but I don't
love them like I really want you to
aspire anything within me no but
actually I loved Emily's house Emily
yeah her mom's house yeah and they live
in like the cutest neighborhood oh
that's cute I also really love the town
what's new house it's like my goals to
two staircases yeah it's been a real one
house in the OC right now I think I
think so too
exciting for that actually it's that
super tough competition with caseta mr.
winner may default southern charm valley
it was like super boring until the last
five minutes and I was like really
annoyed the whole time like watching
Shep and Craig would be like such morons
and [ __ ] and this is like my this is
my cross to bear when watching reality
TV is like getting to know people off TV
and then watching him on TV it's like I
wanted to punch Shep in the face but I
actually really liked him yeah you had a
case of Kelly Teddy Mellencamp syndrome
I've a case of Leeanne Locken syndrome
yeah it's tough no I feel that way about
Shep right now like he's got a lot of
splaining to do at the Reunion this
wasn't his best moment in the season but
I do still really like him and I'm ready
to forgive and then he must apologize
because yeah three something was awful
no and I think in in the middle of the
night Craig realized like he was being
used in this like I don't know how he
didn't realize it sooner but I think he
realized like he was like it involved in
this plan to like try and like hurt
Madison and Austin and that's not what
he planned she did when he felt really
bad because I don't think Craig is a bad
guy I just think he's like a little like
silly you know ya know and he's been
really good guy this season and honestly
he's always picking the right fight I'm
where he's at cross in a Madison could
we talk about Catherine's look she
looked amazing at the party yet with the
big red jacket and yeah I care about
hanging out yeah she did look amazing
looked amazing and she
looks amazing at the reunion in previews
I think is her hair parted down the
middle yeah it's part of the way it was
when she showed up to your party yes
when she said it's my party I couldn't
believe her hair was parted down the
middle because she's always done this
like huge side part which is cool but
it's just not my style and I just know
the potential her hair could be like
with a middle part and it looked so good
I'm glad that she did that the reunion
yeah I'm really happy for her like
getting her getting her life back I've
been like a little you know on and off
with Danny but when Danny came out to
console' Madison before Madison even
apologized like that was really nice it
was and she didn't have to do that
it was really nice she's like women
supporting women and you know who I wish
you know if you know I was a little
annoyed with Cameron yes because she was
laughing no and like for the entire
series
she hasn't claimed herself to be like
kind of the moral compass like she
determines what side like she's she's
almost like a Patricia she's like a mini
Patricia people listen to her and he's a
narrator she'll be married eventually
she's gonna be the voice of reason in
charge of the narrative that's what a
narrator does and she just like was
really not taking a side and like
laughing with the with the girls from
the threesome and like I don't know I
just think like she was really being
super immature about it and it's like oh
now you decided to take a backseat on
everything when let you ruin Catherine's
life yeah I agree or at the very least
like Oh chef brought the girls from the
threesome like don't laugh and and
encourage him and to think it's funny
yeah it was really it was pissing me off
I thought the same thing okay and then
also later in the night like she sits
down with him and scolds him but it's
like you already you already endorsed it
yeah also like Catherine had the
greatest reaction when Kathak Athens
like so not involved in that drama but
then when she heard that chef brought
those two girls she literally was like
Shep you're a dick like that's how a
normal person would respond 100% and
love Katherine and the more things that
happen like the more I'm I ship my ship
is coming in for us in in Madison oh my
god Sam and when we saw them together at
my party they said they were together
but then I'm watch shop inside like two
nights ago he said that they were it so
I don't really know but I need to talk
about watch outside last night did you
watch no because I was watching the
society 50 cent and Kate Upton first of
all like any excuse to see Kate Upton at
my screen like living for it and why is
she promoting she's like doing this new
strong woman workout that like I didn't
really care about but like I was just
like loving to see her on my screen you
know and then 50 cent was on and I
wasn't really excited to see
and then I remembered the softie of it
all and and he made the whole episode
about 50 like it was so funny and
actually some really interesting tidbits
of information hit me one he has not
spoken to Randall and Lala since the
whole debacle like they are actually
fighting to he's not gonna their wedding
anymore even though he was going to be a
groomsman three he actually didn't loan
Randall money out right and then like
asked for it back they were involved in
a business deal where ran to like owed
the business 1.3 million hours and never
paid it back so it wasn't like an
outright like a little Randall needed
the money you know
he's fine that's good to hear yeah it
was upsetting though because I really
for Lala sake like 1 and 50 cent to be
at her wedding yet to be like a
groomsman alongside Jax Taylor yeah 50
in Jax but also like really 50 cent was
just like dropping bombs like he doesn't
give a [ __ ] ready he was saying one time
he went in Atlanta to a strip club with
Bow Wow
and now I didn't have any money so like
you know he just like hand it over like
a couple of G's in singles and I guess
Bow Wow like didn't use it and took it
home with him and then was on Instagram
like flexing with the money so they all
like called him out is like that's my
[ __ ] money give it back Patti so sad
that's almost as cringy as remember him
in the private plane where he posted on
Instagram like a picture background with
a private plane and was like you know
like traveling when someone was like
sitting next I'm just like you're on my
flight like commercial yeah I remember
that I remember that also another crazy
thing 50 cent said and and I think when
when when auntie asked hit I don't think
50 cent was happy and he said is it true
or false at you one time paid on I went
to her 25 thousand dollars for a ticket
to the Met Ball and you said yeah yeah
but it's like I didn't the way the
question was phrased is unfair it's like
you don't pay anna wintour like a venmo
you know it's like you buy a ticket buy
a table yeah that's not as is
embarrassing I know but the way we place
the chair needs for the means for the
children for the children
okay now let's talk about the society
okay but so what did Kate Upton talk
about on the show oh you know she was
getting asked like a lot of salacious
questions and if she didn't do it she
would after like show off 104 new
workout moves unless she kept showing
off her workout moves because she was
like what designer they're answering
this question or promote what you're
here to promote right she said a
designer um once told her like she
didn't wait too much personality to ever
really make it and then Andy was like
which designer and she wouldn't say so
it's like who cares um she would be like
a little tight-lipped but she does watch
all Bravo should watch this Beverly
Hills she was like
she did say something that really
annoyed making she's talking about dog a
she was like I just wish more people
would talk about like the fact like
Hillary gave up her dog like which is
just like the finished argument that was
really not like him which makes me think
she might be a tell VP scan and it also
makes me think like she didn't watch the
reunion where Derrida explains what she
did and why she did it and it makes
simply tons ya know it was it was really
frustrating that's frustrating she's
also up atomic Sam cute I've heard
really great things it's just like
that's such an undertaking
I watched Potomac when it's on I don't I
don't keep up with it but I've
definitely feel like I'm getting there
with my I might actually be starting to
watch a tweak tweak because it's [ __ ]
good and the fact that they have footage
with one of their camera people who
claims that that girl Ashley's husband
Michael touched him like it's so crazy
that's crazy it's crazy time this
society before we wrap so Margaery me
watch his show on Netflix and then know
what it was about and like all this kids
get on a bus and I didn't know what the
point was I thought it's gonna be like a
Riverdale like high school drama which I
was here for me I thought they were
gonna like go to the mountains and like
drama and see ya know it's a sleepy with
you but then all of a sudden the buses
turn around and it's like this parallel
universe where all their parents are
gone and it is the most amazing show
first of all I just love it's it's like
a dystopia it's a really interesting
concept for a show like what happens
it's like the real world when people
stop being play you know you start
getting real it's like it's just such an
interesting concept for a show where
it's like a Lord of the Flies but it
stills kind of civilization like they
have houses and running water it's super
interesting yeah and like someone's
keeping the lights on right and they
don't know if the electricity is ever
gonna run out or if the water is gonna
run out but I feel like it's not I don't
think that it's they can only move back
into their own houses yeah that was like
I understood why
Casali was doing what she was doing with
Chandra Cassandra uh but that was like a
really tight suite after six month we
have all have homes after six months I
think they could have realized and they
could have like led up on that but in
the first week it was definitely a good
idea yeah also people shouldn't be alone
at the time ya know and the housing
thing I didn't agree with put all the
other rules that the motel last name
sisters ah yes I hadn't remember I
camera is it Pennbrook no no I'm kinda
mad that's what I'm thinkin it's hard to
remember everyone's names on the shadow
page of me forever
the hardest time they were like where's
Kelly I'm like who the [ __ ] is Kelly
right and she doesn't look like a Kelly
that's the problem
no one like book feels like their name
yeah Catherine Madison look I hope now
addicted to pills can't remember his
name Harry Harry
I could use a Tyler no no did you see um
Harry Styles at the ariana grande
concert in London like dancing it up
with Billy Bobby Brown yeah I don't
think that means that they're dating
she's so yeah Mason Ramsay is gonna be
so there's something really weird about
Millie Bobby Brown where it's like all
the men in the world forget that she's
12 years old and like has braces and I
wanna have sex with her it's shall we I
think that they are just friends like I
really wouldn't she breaks me how many
older men is she got to be friends with
that's all Minister yes a good point
how many miles so like I stand by the
way I don't think he's into her um I
just think he was being polite but like
just something about Pressman Ali and
Cassandra Pressman they I wasn't a
satisfy but in the very last episode
like my prom I was having a hard time
with this show because it was like a
little slow it's like my focus is like
what's going on here whereas like the
focus of the show was like how do we
make life livable here which is
obviously less interesting cuz I just
want to know how they got there so in
the very last scene when like homegirl
by the way the best part is the mom is
Linda from Blue Bloods I know you don't
watch but like she just got killed over
Blue Bloods and like I'm so glad she
found work you know no literally it's
jarring I think about her I'm like
worried about her okay but it was like
that's 20 seconds she got chef to
episode she got more than all the other
parents that's that's true whose mom is
she
Pressman Pressman and she's the mayor no
no she was just doing like a dancer
first episode again newsstand
but I saw the bus driver in all of the
picture me too when they were looking at
pictures of Cassandra for her funeral I
mean a hundred times it showed these
photos and this first thing I saw you
know who was pissing me off like the
entire season but then really towards
the end was the pregnant girl like I
felt for you like you're gonna have the
first baby in this new world but like
stop being such a [ __ ] to the dude
who's literally so [ __ ] nice to you
when he has no reason to be right Ennio
Brewin a it's like like you finally
found love with any boy the other gay
person no and the best guy in town grace
I'm [ __ ] live regrets honestly I for
a moment I was shipping Grizz with like
Ali Bey because he was like protecting
her and I was just like living for it
but then I'm like no Grizz and Sam here
for it it's like they're the only gay
people in the town but they also have a
genuine connection like I was so here
for it and then [ __ ] pregnant girls
out here ruining it yeah no way she was
being like she was being so mean she was
so mean
I think that's pregnancy like she is
pregnant she's giving birth like 50%
chance of survival in no technology and
like nobody actually thinks that they
had sex no yeah so they just look stupid
yeah I wish like Sam could just tell her
he's like I'm being a good guy you
should actually like me more yeah no I
know why he can't same because they have
to take it to the grave you can't just
like tell a few people and then lie down
like you know what it's like the world
is so big I'm sorry the world is so
small now like no one gives a [ __ ] who
your baby daddy is we're trying to slip
you know we're trying to make it back to
earth but maybe that's why it's so crazy
farmlands like I actually was going to
cry but I Marga said it and I thought
the same thing like there's no way they
come back in the farmland is still there
yeah really it's just like I just don't
think that the people that are pulling
the strings like once success here right
and so it's like they found this land
and then they're gonna go back and it's
gonna be gone right and they were just
like turkeys on the land is true I don't
think so I think they have they found
this line and it'll still be there it's
the only way for like the show to go on
otherwise they die in like a month
that's true when that girl came into
Chris's tent it was like trying to [ __ ]
I'm like get the [ __ ] out of here all
over the place the whole series right
she was dating one of the guards right
and then they stay on same room because
they didn't to give up there's couples
room really relatable but you should
also was like talking to Cass at like
talking [ __ ] - Cassandra being like no
one liked you in high school right it's
like shut up no some of the girls when
some of the girls are like so stupidly
dangerous that like it pisses me Lexie
Lexie she was also the one whose mom is
a hoarder and her house is like full of
goods oh yeah I realize that as I'm
sitting ready this morning with her back
I guess you know there's no better time
to be a horror than when the world ends
you know
yeah I'm sure percent no I think they're
never getting off this is like a lesson
in like it's a micro political situation
right um and now they need to like learn
how to live and have babies and get
married and not try and kill each other
right and at the city live on a kibbutz
I was thinking this show isn't about
like they'll always be this thing like
how did we get here how do we go home
but the show is about the society of
right this is what happens when like 250
high school students are left to their
own devices and the
without anything else yeah and I'm glad
they're addressing the fact that's like
we missed our parents like there's some
things he going on here that we actually
do like yeah like I can't smoke pot
without my parents that's what we said
the entire it makes no sense between the
liquor store and all their houses that
actually I don't know but the amount
that they've been drink they drink every
night yeah it's been six months of like
heavy drinking every night there's no
way I thought they were gonna run out of
alcohol at the party at the church the
first yeah yeah it literally makes no
sense I'm so worried about like their
resources and they're not and that's the
problem and it shows also what do you
think so what do the parents think
happened that they like all died on the
bus yes yeah interesting
oh so the smell is weird there's
something yeah there's excuse me
I mean maybe we'll get answers but
probably not what and whatever the
answer is it's gonna be like some black
marriage [ __ ] we're like parallel like
nothing explainable nothing that teaches
us any I don't even care I'm just like
so happy to have a good interesting
compelling TV show on my screen but now
we have to wait a full year cuz it
literally came out in May
whatever I've been following them all on
Instagram and it's making it so much
easier Luke except they all post
together except with Allie no Allie post
with all of them but I was trying to
find her Instagram through the cast's
Instagram and it took me forever I had
to go back to the society she's the most
famous one and she was in big little
lies now she's like I think she might be
right and she was also in bad teacher
the best movie ever where she's the girl
Skylar and the kid is gymnastics
sweatshirt is in love with her so I
think that she might just be like above
she think she's better you know but
crazy process got went to the mecca our
she did Chanel what yeah she's like she
like can't catch a break like she should
be really famous like she ain't nobody
maybe those are name is clue I feel like
these kids are actually the best example
of like the new wave where it's like
we're coming up through Netflix and
awesomeness TV and like Hulu and these
are what movie stars are today yeah but
like we don't really know that you know
these kids are really like really
supremely talented yeah
but this is like they're coming in
through the back doors this ship may
have sailed but their ship no their
yacht may have sailed but their ship is
coming in okay well that's all we got
for you today thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast which
isn't a lot millennial Morning Show I'm
sure you know you can listen to us on
YouTube
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time feel free to subscribe give this
video a thumbs up leave a comment about
how beautiful we are I don't know with
you you decide we're also available as a
podcast for your commuter like listen to
podcast take train long sandy ferry take
the ferry I'm head over to iTunes
Spotify stitcher anyway you can listen
to podcasts subscribe there also leave a
five star view be like oh my god this
girl is so smart malaria it's like how
did I not live with them before you know
you decide it's oh we're not picky we're
not picking you guys so much girl with
no job follow me on Instagram Jackie oh
problems please bye see you tomorrow
you